[Musique]
la sous préfecture du sud la plus grande
marina de martinique tout cela aux
marins et sort qu'elle dit accueille
aujourd'hui la première adjointe au
maire de cette commune yvonne fritz
bonjour bonjour monsieur vient de tomber
j'en à tous merci d'être avec nous une
sous-préfecture et la marina le marais
ne se résume pas qu'à cela n'est ce pas
non du tout alors le port de la commune
qui est en pleine expansion que de
chemin parcouru depuis 1985 et c'est
d'abord parce là que le marin rayonne
yvonne fritz oui oui bien sûr et bien
évidemment par l'action oc et des marées
noires en règle générale sur le terrain
c'est vrai que le port de plaisance
c'est pas une marina fait un port de
plaisance puisqu'il y à d'autres
services à rattacher en tout cas
l'activité purement de plaisance et
s'éteint c'est un port qui est
aujourd'hui le plus grand de la caraïbe
du sud
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui quels sont les enjeux c'est
la formation c'est l'emploi pour les
jeunes marinois les jeunes martiniquais
à travers cet outil
oui bien sûr alors il y a bien fallu
trouver à l'époque de la fermeture de
l'usiné du marin en 1969 une orientation
pour contrer cet exode de rural que
connaissait le marin et puis développer
l'économie de quoi faire un c'est par le
travail qu'on attire la population donc
les différents conseils municipaux ou
non monsieur rodolphe désiré a été maire
depuis 83 et y ont travaillé ont
travaillé en partenariat avec le secteur
privé d'où aujourd'hui ce port de
plaisance me et aussi le carénage
c'est vraiment un ensemble portuaire les
infrastructures ont été pesées et s'est
posé à un certain moment aussi là le
marketing qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
mettre en avant cette activité au delà
des actions qui sont faites sur le
terrain
donc ça a été aussi le travail de
l'office de tourisme du marin en
partenariat bien évidemment par
convention avec
le conseil municipal et il a été
question justement de parler du marin à
l'extérieur et surtout d'attirer chez
nous des transatlantiques alors y en a
une qui ça fait trente ans qu'elle vit
en martinique dont on n'a rien inventé
mais il n'empêche qu'il a fallu tenir la
cadence pour que des visiteurs et des
professionnels aussi de la navigation
lienne connaître nos infrastructures et
ange arif objectif alors finalement
alors aujourd'hui qu'il ya quelqu'un là
la future barre à atteindre et ben oui
c'est bien évidemment continuer la
création d'emplois parce qu'aujourd'hui
à ses infrastructures
ce sont plus de 700 emplois directs ce
sont plus de 200 emplois indirects
1 on voit tous les commerces qui sont
aussi venus s'installer mais aussi le
personnel de santé aussi qu'ils venaient
s'installer et la formation
donc la formation vous savez que les
municipalités sont son participent en
tout cas à l'organisation des écoles
primaires 1
mais au delà il s'agit directement des
services
aujourd'hui de la collectivité
territoriale pour les infrastructures et
bien évidemment l'académie le travail
que nous faisons par exemple sur le
marin avec nos écoles primaires depuis
quelques années c'est justement
l'apprentissage aux langues étrangères
parce que ça c'est très important c'est
déjà un début ensuite nous travaillons
beaucoup avec le lycée professionnel
raymond et russe pour nous il est
important et ça tombe très bien
aujourd'hui le gouvernement parle de
réforme des lycées professionnels
nous y travaillons depuis quelques
années mais pas qu'au gouvernement
nous n'attendons en règle générale par
le gouvernement est ce que vous avez
réussi à imposer ce que vous vouliez
votre vision du développement économique
de la ville dumas mais à travers à
travers son port est ce que par exemple
au niveau du lycée professionnel c'était
facile de dire doublons telle et telle
filière parce que nous pensons que
demain dans 10 ans d'emprisonnement mais
temple comme nous aurons besoin de ce
type de métier non nous n'avons pas
décidé de l'affilié à la filière
nautisme est existait mais il n'empêche
que
nous avons besoin les professionnels le
secteur privé a besoin justement de
personnes nous former de bons
techniciens avec du matériel approprié
et nous nous avons essayé de mettre en
relation en tout cas des professionnels
l'industrie du nautisme avec le lycée
professionnel raymond et russes et nous
avons trouvé aussi à les mettre en
relation avec le lycée professionnel
éric tabarly au sable de l'année alors
vous avez un plan un plan ville voilà
c'est la continuité on va laisser ce
secteur très économique très porteur
pour faire autre chose entre landes
travers ce secteur du nautisme
non en fait c'est une activité toute
activité à à plusieurs branches 1 donc
il ya la partie professionnelle
mais pour continuer pouvoir garder ce
rythme il faut bien évidemment intégrer
notre population parce que c'est aussi
une découverte pour pour notre
population qu'elle soit marinoise ou
martinique est en règle générale c'est
vraiment s'approprier la mer et
s'appropriait la mer bien évidemment ces
nounous l'accompagnement que nous avons
nous aurons dès le début de la rentrée
prochaine avec notamment les classes de
cm1 c'est un choix des directeurs
d'école et du rectorat de faire en sorte
que ces enfants systématiquement à un
stage de voile gratuit donc c'est là la
ville qui organisa avec le club de voile
notre club nautique du marin nous avons
fait les travaux afin de pouvoir les
installer sur la plage du bourg afin
qu'ils soient dans une zone sécurisée
les 300 mètres balisé pour recoller
laisser ses enfants apprennent la mer
dans une eau propre dans une au muy tout
à fait propre où il n'ya pas y'a pas de
soucis vous voyez bien tous les relever
montre que la baie du lorrain n'a aucun
problème puisque le développement du
nautisme va aussi avec respect de
l'environnement vous savez que les
nouvelles technologies ainsi que voilà
maintenant
maintenant effectivement on sait bien
que tout ce qui va à la mer vient aussi
de la terre alors yvonne fritz le port
du marais vous avez des ambitions pour
cette structure
un moment les communes avoisinantes
n'ont pas toujours bien compris il ya
même eu quelques tensions notamment
pense à cette année aujourd'hui tout est
réglé est ce que les maires voisins ont
compris qu'ils pouvaient bénéficier
profite également de cette structure est
ce que tout le monde regarde dans la
même direction aujourd'hui alors le il
faut il faut pas penser que marin
sainte-anne martinique il faut voir
aussi que nous avons nous sommes un
département français
nous avons 20 des lois qui font aussi
qu' aujourd'hui en dehors des 300 mètres
tout le reste du plan d'eau et sous
gestion de l'état donc la question con
qu'on travaille en tout cas les points
qu'on travaille avec les services de
l'état et notamment la direction de la
mer vous parliez tout à l'heure de sous
préfecture mais mme la sous préfète est
très engagé aussi à nos côtés là dessus
c'est de faire en sorte que l'état nous
accompagnent parce qu'aujourd'hui on
leur dit vous dites que vous n'avez pas
les moyens
vous ne comprenez pas tout à fait le
système et le développement du nautisme
et je parle pas forcément des
représentants de l'état ici en
martinique mais est tout tout tout vient
de paris entre guillemets et de leur
dire voici ce que nous voulons donc
aujourd'hui nous nous retrouvons
régulièrement sur justement
l'organisation de cette belle
on parle de la bms marin sainte anne en
sachant que nous avons obtenu de l'état
95 hectares supplémentaires dans la
gestion donc une gestion en plus des 25
hectares cas aujourd'hui en gestion la
capitainerie donc le port de plaisance
et c'est de dire nous allons organiser
les mouillages
ce seront des mouillages payant d'accord
donc ça veut dire que ce sont des
ressources supplémentaires pour nous
ville de sainte anne et et ville du
marin chacun sur nos territoires
et oui nous travaillons ensemble
maintenant c'est vrai que ce n'est pas
évident à comprendre parce que souvent
on dit d'un tel territoire appartient à
telle ville sauf que dans la ville même
dans l'organisation du littoral
dans l'organisation du plan d'eau il y a
plein de facteurs et d'intervenants et
le tout c'est concerné que c'était ce
que c'est plus rivière pilote le voc ne
le force pas se dit tu vois qu arriver
et barret mais ce cadeau m'y adonne dé
l'hôtel qui l'accueille nous ça aussi
c'est important
ah oui c'est très important et ce qu'on
explique justement dans lequel justement
du classement qu'on veut de la ville
qu'on aimerait qu'on souhaiterait de la
ville du marin en station tourisme c'est
vraiment nous nous expliquons et nous
continuons à dire au service de l'état
et notamment au ministère des affaires
étrangères au secrétariat d'état au
tourisme et c'est que on ne peut pas
avoir la même vision d'un continent et
du nil qu'aujourd'hui le marin oui nous
nous aimerions avoir un hôtel et nous
aurons un hôtel en jour mais il
n'empêche que développer les maisons
d'hôtes dans les quartiers accompagner
ces familles dans des compléments de
salaires quand nous avons nos
navigateurs qui arrive sur le marin
qu'il puisse aller résidé quelques jours
à sainte luce a rivière pilote au
vauclin à sainte anne ça ne nous pose
aucun problème et les frontières non
nous n'avons pas de frontières
alors aujourd'hui quand on arrête
deviendra une sorte de hub
nous sommes sommes maintenant un hub il
ne s'agit pas de recevoir des
plaisanciers
on reçoit des plaisanciers puis aussi la
location de bateaux sur le marin c'est
un hub mais un hub qui intègre sa
population et qui fait en sorte
justement que tous ces touristes qui
arrivent tous ses visiteurs qui arrivent
puissent consommer bien évidemment aux
marins les marées noires sont au courant
et le voit mais aussi que tout le
territoire du sud et non de la
martinique nous c'est très intéressant
que plaisanciers arrive et qu'il aille
j'ai enfin à fond saint denis quelques
jours c'est très bien pour l'économie
martiniquaise
alors vous savez que puisque vous l'avez
évoqué la législation cette évolution de
la législation en ce qui concerne les
communautés d'agglomération font que
mais par ifop l'espace sud a la
compétence pour gérer le tourisme sur
ces zones géographiques sauf que sauf
que le marin ne veut pas forcément de
cette façon de voir les choses
vous voulez garder votre gestion de
votre office du tourisme
on en est où la démarche était
comme ici c'est pas bien mais sur la
façon de vous annoncer la chose or c'est
non nous ne s'est pas que nous ne
voulons pas puisque de toute façon nous
travaillons avec la communauté de
l'espace sud c'est clair c'est net
nous avons notamment une
convention-cadre pourront tout ce qui
est développement du territoire à partir
du label européen ont dit ces gars qui
dit bien que ce label européen c'est une
dynamique qui met justement en phase les
activités de la mer et des activités de
l'intérieur dont croissance bleue et
croissance verte donc bien évidemment il
faut que ça parte d'un port il y à des
investissements qui ont été faits par la
ville du marin il y à une organisation
qui a été mise en place sur la ville du
marin l'office de tourisme marin est le
seul office aujourd'hui classé en
catégorie 1 la plus haute catégorie
donc ce sont des critères nationaux 1
nous sommes classés communes
touristiques
nous avons demandé le classement en
station tourisme à partir du moment où
il ya eu la loi note et l'habilitation a
été donnée aux au comité d'agglomération
pour tout ce qui est promotion et
animations touristiques
il y a eu tout de suite un décret le
décret montagne qui disait que toutes
les communes qui avait déjà engagé soit
qui était déjà classée station tourisme
ou alors qu'ils étaient engagés dans un
dossier qui avait déjà déposé un dossier
qui en instruction pour ce classement en
attendant la réponse d'accord reste
toujours leur office reste toujours un
objet de communes
vous êtes optimiste sur ce dossier alors
nous sommes nous répondre à tous les
critères qui sont des critères nationaux
et tout à l'heure je vous disais que le
point d'achoppement c'est réellement ce
nombre d'hébergements qu'on nous demande
mais d'un nombre d'hébergements en hôtel
est aussi un autre résidence mais classé
d'accord on pourcentage correspond à peu
près 70 % et nous nous disons aux
services de l'état
mais comment est-ce que vous pouvez nous
comparer nous il avec des régions ou des
villes qui sont peut-être plus petit en
nombre d'habitants mais avec une
superficie beaucoup plus grande
nous quand on passe d'une ville à
l'autre à 7km quelqu'un sort du port et
va être hébergé à à sainte-anne et donc
c'est un point d'achoppement
ceci étant l'espoir reste toujours
présent et nous espérons en tout cas
pour la martinique que mon qu'elle est
qu'elle est une ville qui soit classée
station tourisme parce que est classée
station tourisme ça fait entrer dans un
grand réseau international ce sont des
reconnaissances et pour nos villes du
marin dans l'action que nous menons
parce que nous accueillons des visiteurs
c'est aussi que notre notre budget de
fonctionnement augmentent justement
grâce au classement merci d'avoir été ce
matin avec non ils vont triste de voir
tel que vous êtes maire-adjointe à la
commune du marin je suis fatigué sur un
quart de seconde
monsieur désiré sera candidat en 2020
vous pouvez l'appeler ya pas de problème
[Musique]